لا تصحيح المعلومه كان كان الاتفاق في
البدايه انه 50% خمسين في الميه يعني
شراكه كامله
لاحقا تلكات الكثير من الدول العربيه
وخاصه كما ذكرت في في
مكتب على السن الدول الجمهوريه التقدميه
الاشتراكيه
تركت كثيرا واصبح المعاد في ازمه فاتفق
على انه 40% من الجانب العربي هو 60% من
جانب
اهل الفرنسي وبعد هذا حصل تنصت الدول
العربيه كلها من الالتزام كل شيء رسمي
لماذا لانه كان في اجتهاد من احد المدراء
المعهد انه اعطونا ما تبقى لديكم ونحن
سنستثمر ونستغني عن هذه المطالبات السنويه
غير المضمونه
استثمر حوالي خمسين مليون يورو لم يكن
يعمل شيئا وبالتالي الان لا ليس هناك دوله
عربيه تسهم بشكل منتظم في ميزانيه المعهد
فقط تابع لوزاره الخارجيه وزاره الخارجيه
مشكوره تتحمل الجزء الاكبر من ميزانه
المهد هناك دعم وهذا شيء كما تعلم غير غير
المنتظم يعني غير رسمه
وللامانه السعوديه والامارات وبعضهم
الخليج لها الدوره الاكبر في الحفاظ على
هذه العلاقه وهذه خساره كبرى لانه كل
الدول الديمقراطيه في اوروبا لو ان
الموضوع من البدايه سلم لي
المنظمه العربيه للعلوم
والفنون او لجامعه الدول العربيه واصبحت
واصبحت الميزانيه او الحصتنا من ميزانيه
المنتظمه لا ربما المعهد يعني ضاعف جهده
في سبيل خدمه الثقافه العربيه رغم انه
يلعب دوره حاسم ودور مهم جدا جدا الى
اليوم في الترويج لاجمل الصور والمنتوجات
الفنيه والمعرفيه والجماليه من القديم
والحديث في الفضاء العربي لكنه كما قلت
قبل قليل وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه ومدخلات
المعهد والا للاسف الشديد العرب تخلوا عن
هذه الجوهره الباريسيه
انا اعتقد انه وليس هذا كلامي حتى الاستاذ
خالد العنقري كان يكرر نفس الكلام ان هذا
مكسب فريد من نوعه مؤسسه فريده من نوعها
في العالم اليونسكو للعالم كله ما احد
الارم العربي ينافس اليونسكو في مبناهي
وموقعه وانشطته ومع ذلك لم نتنبه له بشكل
جيد وبالتالي يكرر الشكر لبعض الدول
الخليجيه التي لا تزال تعي قيمه المعهد
وتدعمه بشكل شبه منتظم